in the name of allah the gracious the merciful
all praise is due to allah the lord of the universe the master of the day
of judgment
i bear witness and testimony to the oneness of allah
to his magnificence his omnipotence his might his glory to his being the creator and sustainer
of all things the giver of life to guider of hearts the master of the day
of judgment
now bear witness to the fact that muhammad
servants and final messenger
may the peace and blessings of the lord be upon him and upon all those who
choose to tread in his path until the last day
it is said
that towards the end of ramadan the prophet
would regularly engage in a practice known as the
secluding himself to nothing other than the masjid
and as we ready and prep ourselves for the coming month of ramadan within this month
of sha'an may allah make it means a blessing for us and enable us to meet
that blessed month of ramadan in as best of a state as possible
this is a key practice within the prophetic tradition that we want to start to reflect
upon
the word ethical itself refers to a specific
practice that the prophet engaged in
where he would separate himself from the meccan society in which he lived and seclude himself
to the masjid for the final 10 days and nights of the month of ramadan
he said that in the last year of his life he did 20.
there's some narrations that say that at times he might have missed some because of illness
and he even made those up in other months
but it's a practice that he was regularly engaged in
and that seeking of solitude wasn't something that he and the companions engaged in solely in
the month of ramadan that you have narrations in our tradition that would say that there
would be times when they would enter into the masjid even if just for a few
hours some moments
and they would sit the way that we are seated but they would sit with the
intention of it being an attic off for them
and some would use this as a basis of being able to say that if you're
not able to do the full ten but you can do a portion of it you
still should
and beyond that generation you see within every generation even before he became a prophet and
prophets before him they would have this is a regular practice
he separates himself from the bani ashrael for 40
money days peace be upon her she seeks seclusion in the temple at a time when
let alone women were not doing this nobody was doing it
our prophets
he is seeking solitude in places like the cave of heroes in places where nobody else
would be but they would by chance go across and they would find him there all
by himself
it's in these spaces
where big things also happen
when moses peace be upon him finds that solitude
he speaks to allah
mary and peace be upon her when she is in her seclusion in her solitude
the gifts of fruits come to her from just allah alone
the prophet in his solitude
becomes now recipient of the first revelation
that's the nature of what is possible when you're able to do it with regularity
i want you to think about this in a few different frames
in the prism of modernity we have so much that is in advancement it's undeniable
you can see that interconnectivity exists in a mode that no one could have even imagined
years ago
the realities of how we can communicate
through technological apparatus the innovation of scientific advancement and so much more
in the prism of modernity there also is gaps that exist
and one of the most crucial gaps that impacts each of us and so many in
the world's existence right now is a diminishing of places of stillness and reflection
want you to think as an individual
where do you go to rest
where do you go to just disconnect
where do you go where you don't stare at your phone in the midst of anything
you don't respond to every vibration and every notification
where do you go where you're not away from people but you can be away from
distractions
that allow for you to utilize the ocular that was given to you to simply now
engage in the practice of contemplation reflection
you want to think about how we differ from the rest of creation
the rest of creation necessitates compulsive action in order for them to exist
and most creatures in creation also are in a space where you don't necessarily see them
in isolation other than when we as humans live in ways other than we're supposed to
so it's always a school of fish it's always a flock of birds it's always a
herd of cattle
but you and i
we exist individually at times
and the way that a creature in creation necessitates compulsive action in order to exist to
do what it does
you and i uniquely
in creation
are qualified not just as humans but human beings
because we can be human simply by just being
there's a different recognition of what we're endowed with individually
and in the prism of modernity when you live in a consumer-based society that is constantly
telling you to feed the physical feed the physical feed the physical
it has you run on default settings chasing after something day in and day out day
in and day out
you don't take moments to stop and deliberately breathe you don't take moments to stop and
deliberately rest
to reflect to contemplate
and what's getting stifled is not growth in all of its forms
but really the only aspect that you and i remain to have evolution in
that's an ever-evolving potential in our consciousness
i want you to just think for a moment
when was the last time you paused to just reflect
when was the last time you built into your strategy for the coming weeks the coming
month an opportunity to just be in a place of contemplation
if that strategy is not something that's coming willfully how do you know that the direction
that you're going in is a direction that is going to bear you an end point
where you in fact believe you need to be in order for you to have entry
points to the best of places in the world beyond this one we have everybody just
move up and come in close
and this is what they were doing
with regularity
throughout the months
but in ramadan in particular
the i take off was something that the prophet salaam did not leave behind
the word itself
it is derived from the arabic roots
which denotes being committed to something
you're in a place now where that seclusion in that masjid
is heavily rooted now to what we fundamentally understand ramadan to be about you are that
much more strategic about what it is that you are consuming throughout the course of your
ramadan day
not just about the
abandonment of food and drink but so much more
everything that's going into you now is devoid of negativity
you're sitting in the masjid in etiquette
you're not hearing anybody gossip and curse
you're sitting in the masjid and it's you're not hearing anybody tell you why it is
that you are inadequate in some way
you're hearing verses recited that are speaking to you about your beauty the inherent nature of
your goodness what you can aspire towards in terms of being somebody who's not afraid to
dream
you're hearing words that are talking to you about a god that believes in you more
than you believe in yourself
a god that is looking for a reason to accept from you and not push you
away
a religion that's not merely an identity variable but something that you live and you practice
you embody within a connection to a tradition that transcends 14 lived centuries of practice
you're around people
who are going to uplift
because they too have hearts that are now not being impacted by so much of the
negative that exists
and it's in ramadan so
suffer changed
when i was a freshman at nyu
ramadan was around christmas time
a lot of you who were maybe not even born at that point
it's really really crazy to think about
and it was the first time i ever made it off in my life i was
18 years old
i couldn't do the full 10 nights because of my final exam schedule
but the minute my exam finished i got on a train with a bag from my
dorm went to a masjid that i used to go to growing up in central new
jersey and i stayed there for the next six and a half days and nights the
last in ramadan
the masjid was filled with a lot of younger people because of the holiday time
what we engaged in was so much that you can imagine
prayers and quran recitation
but it was also about what we were not engaging in
i didn't hear anybody fight in those nights
not one person raised their voices
in a way that was antagonistic or filled with retributive anger
right he says raise your words not your voices it is the rain that makes the
flowers grow not the thunder
i didn't hear anybody lie
and i didn't have anybody to lie to or gossip with as well
i wasn't in a place where what i was consuming was now simply not just about
my food and my drink but the day-to-day consumption
and i left the masjid
and i walked out his front door
and the world just looked so different man
i can still picture what that same parking lot was that i used to drive in
day after day after day when i was a teenager trying to figure out what religion
meant to me
but what i remember even more starkly
is the first argument that i heard thereafter
and the way that it just struck my heart
like somebody was literally stabbing me because i hadn't heard that kind of noise
for days
my dua as i left the masjid was that ya allah let my heart continue to
quake when i hear things like this
i don't want to lose that
i don't want to become desensitized to a place where there's not something that causes me
to tremble and shudder when i hear somebody mistreating somebody else
or god forbid it's my own voice that i hear pushing down someone instead of bringing
them up
i want you to think about this in anticipation
because there are students that go to this school and other schools that i know
are not going to be able to do ten days and nights of it
they're professionals who are part of our community
that work remotely they go to offices they also will not be able to do a
full 10 days or 10 nights
but a lot of them are going to plant
and they're going to say the weekend is upon me
there's no place else i'm going to be other than seeking that solitude
saturday is there and rather than thinking about what i cannot accomplish i'm going to make
sure that i find a space for now where i'm able to engage in that practice
there's different opinions on where it must be done
everyone says the masjid should be the case
some exceptions are made in terms of being able to do it in your home
there's 200 mosques in new york city
find one from now but you don't have to get along with everybody you're not going
there to be there with them you're going to be with allah
be the person that turns to your friend
and says hey should we go do this even if it's just from the evening till
fajr even if it's just for a few hours even if it's just for some moments
in the practice of a sunnah the nawaf the idea is that if you can do
a portion of it you still do a portion of it you break out of the
mindset that says that somehow there's not benefit and just reading one verse of the quran
somebody else can read a whole judge that's fine you can read one verse read a
verse you're not in competition with anybody else the one that you are today is just
in a pursuit of meeting who you can be tomorrow you gotta start someplace
you wanna just taste it
you wanna feel what it's like to be in that kind of space
what it is that you're taking in is absent of what is negative and filled with
what is positive real butter
in the prism of modernity what we also deal with on a consumption level
it's not just now food and drink
but you can go through an entire day
and take in more imagery more sound
consumption through your other organs of sensory perception
in a day in a week
more so than in comparison to what somebody might have done in their whole life decades
ago
the idea of lowering your gaze is not something that should be limited to a simplistic
understanding of gender relations that has us become standoffish to each other as brothers and sisters
you want to be able to elevate the discourse and mature yourself to a place that
recognizes that our book teaches us to be supporters of one another
you can't do that if what you understand this to be is something that is just
at its most base reductive understanding
you lower your gaze in those instances because now as you consume imagery it's staying with
you
when you stand in prayer something that you did not see is not going to just
pop into your head
something that you never heard is not going to somehow just on its own formulate itself
into your psyche
the only things that you can look at in retrospect are the things that you expected
in the first place
and so the idea of being conscious of what it is that you gaze upon is
so that just like you don't want to over eat through your mouth to the point
that it impacts your physical being in a way that holds you back from your potential
growth you also want to be conscious of what it is that you're consuming from the
eyes that you see with the ears that you hear with the hands that you touch
with
when you're in a place of solitude
you're able to now not be away from people but you're able to be away from
distractions
you can start to think objectively
and you can start to strategize that says what are the things that are pulling me
towards things that i'm really wondering why am i going towards those in the first place
make a plan
that you have now six weeks seven weeks
multiple weekends
that are there in that blessed month
that you use some of that time
to re-establish this practice on a communal level for all of our benefits
but individually
you connect now to the prophetic tradition
by introducing into your own life this practice of seclusion
and it's hard there's countries in the world now they have literally hired and established
positions in their governments that are ministers of loneliness
that's not what we're talking about
you can't be afraid to be alone
you can't be afraid to deal with certain things and spaces by yourself
you don't even have to do that there's other people around you
but it's in those moments of solitude
that ideas get cultivated
the creativity
starts to become unbounded
that your courage your boldness moves to a place where it's audacious and it becomes unbounded
and you're not just living the same routine that everybody else is living in a way
where they're in these default robotic settings
and beauty is passing you day after day after day
in a communal sense of existence
your need for solitude is our benefit
because when you capitalize on it when it evolves now is your consciousness
just like fasting
it's about a mindfulness rooted in an ethical impairment you have a book
that is meant to be a guidance for those who have taqwa so all of it
is elevating that potential
so can you imagine
if we started to come together as a community
made up of individuals
who were strong
in their level of consciousness
can you imagine that if our convenings were in a place where our inner selves were
now in a place of reaching their potential high points you're on the brink the verge
of really acquiring
that thing that makes you distinct from the rest of creation
so when i sit and i talk to you we are actually exchanging ideas because you've
thought about things when you were by yourself
that the mode of our interaction was not simply rooted in things that we did a
month ago and we don't even remember now
but i can be bold enough to turn to you and say that hey how do
you think you and i together can build something that's going to leave this world in
a place that's better than how it is that we found it how do you think
that we can aspire towards creating now something that's going to allow for those who get
marginalized and isolated to not feel those things
you have talent
you have skills and credentials
you have networks and resources
you have so much in terms of spiritual gifts
what's missing is the ability to see it
and it's not just with a physical vision it has to be with an inward vision
that allows for you to do that
where do you feel at rest where do you feel at peace
where do you go to rejuvenate to replenish
the spaces that take you out of the classrooms the offices where many convene with an
intention that's just capitalistic about making money and teaching you how to make money you got
to put food on the plate that's not what i'm saying but if it's the only
exposure and that's all that's there
conversations that are just about physical and the physicality and how you feed the physical
and why wouldn't you think the thoughts that you think
taqwa is not just about being somebody who thinks because everybody thinks
but it's about being able to re-harness
the gift the skill
that you choose how you think about the things that you're thinking about
and even before that what it is that you're thinking about in the first place
you want to see people who have this as a practice
somebody who is so built inwardly
that they can actually believe
and embrace the role
of being a final prophet to all of mankind
you can't leave out of the recipe that made the prophet sallallahu alaihi wasallam ready to
accept that and introduce that as an idea to the whole world
the fact that he engaged in reflection and contemplation
if you're not doing it you got to start doing it
and you do it deliberately
building it into your routine
doesn't have to be for hours in a week it doesn't even have to be hours
in a day you just sit five minutes a few minutes reflect upon something exercise that
mental muscle use the cognitive organ that you have that is your heart
and it'll remove all kinds of veils
and allow for you to have a clarity
that as you start to taste it and experience it you're not going to want to
give it up for anybody
where is that place that you can go
a place that would allow for you to be at peace with stillness
a place that would allow for you to engage and want to have solitude
a place where you're not afraid to address and confront your thoughts
but you can start to extrapolate meaning from them
this ramadan
try
make a deliberate attempt
that says i'm going to engage in some of that for myself
you don't have to make it hard on yourself
you don't have to be in a place where you also put down somebody else's effort
somebody tells you that i'm going to pray isha for the first time in jamaa tell
them good job don't tell them well you know you also need to do this this
and this
somebody tells you that i have a need i have an exam tomorrow don't push them
down and make them feel bad but say that if i'm staying and you're going i'm
going to continue to make dua for you and know that allah rewards you for the
intention that you had that you want to be here but you can't
uplifting words
voices that allow for somebody to believe that they still are entitled to build that relationship
with the divine
but at a minimum on this day of juma you start envisioning what is that ramadan
going to look like for me
what are those nights going to look like for me
nights where nobody is turned away
nights where people of all races all classes
nights where everyone comes
young and old backgrounds of anything you can imagine
the only thing that they need for it to be something that yields what they're looking
for is the presence of a wakeful heart
nights where it is apparent beyond anything
what it means that allah is kareem
they're not nights that you want to just leave to chance
and anything else that you think you could be doing in those nights
some that you might be compelled to do but there will be moments if you plan
from now that you can set aside and say even if it's just an hour even
if it's just one of the days i'm going to make sure that i seek some
of that solitude
that i'm going to take advantage and reestablish this practice within a community
so that as an individual i start to increase in that awareness in my connection to
my aka
and then as a community i start to be a key building block
of individuals that are elevated in their ideas their creativity their awareness
so we can go out and build for ourselves we can't expect anybody else to build
for us but that missing ingredient is you more so than anybody
take advantage of it while you have the time to do so
um
whoever
as we get closer to ramadan
is a community we're going to continue to plan
many of you are going to help us volunteer may allah reward you for that there's
going to be specific things that we start to ask of you especially as students
for example there's going to be many students who have classes still as commuters coming in
at 8 a.m in the morning meaning they have to leave their homes at 5 30.
so we're going to ask you as a student population
who is willing to let their peers perhaps stay over for a night so that they
can still benefit from ramadan if you have space even on your floor be the first
to sign up
we're going to do a lot of programs that go till fajr some until two in
the morning different theoms
you're gonna have individuals who are gonna go late at night back and forth to different
parts of the city
so when we reach out to say who has a car that can help to drive
people or who is from what part of the city so that you can go as
a group and no one has to go by themselves in the late hours of the
night or decide to not go to something because they're worried if they're traveling alone what
might happen to them volunteer
the best of you are going to be those who even where you don't have to
get on a train to go somewhere else as a destination you get on the train
you take somebody back to their home and then you come back here
the prophet
comes to talk to him late at night you're not supposed to technically leave the masjid
once you enter for etikov she comes to ask him something the hour is late he
leaves the masjid to walk her back to her house and then comes back to the
masjid to resume his etiquette
there's purpose to this deen
but when those calls go out in the prism of the reality that we find ourselves
in
don't wait for somebody else to sign up for something that you're able to do
but be the first one to say that hey man you can come stay at my
place and you don't even have to stay on the floor the couch you take my
bed i'm gonna sleep on the floor
you remember who your teacher is
you remember what it is that you really gain not by seeing what it is that
you have to give up but where somebody else benefits from things that only you uniquely
can do
we're blessed to now start having some of our non-student community join
technically they were supposed to be coming from next week but some of them got access
today somehow we don't know but that's from a lot so if you see new faces
around you greet them
the crux of this community is our student population
my opinion that the barakah of this space is just the beauty of the students that
attend it and we are blessed to have so many people who live in the outer
boroughs in manhattan that are able to leverage this space as their community space
so in the coming weeks you're going to start to see more of them attending
i think we have maybe a dozen or so with us today and it's good to
see your faces again after so long
i want you all to talk to some of them when you can one brother said
to me that he's been waiting two years to be able to come back to this
room
that's the kind of love people have for the space that we've been sitting in
and so many more when they found out that others were able to come today with
like a good sense of energy saying i wish i could be there also
we come together with the sole purpose of being connected to the divine
and you're going to see what it is that people can achieve when they come together
on a good purpose a good intention
but reach out to new faces just like you would reach out to anyone else and
welcome them back or welcome them for the first time so that when they meet you
you're the reason that they keep coming back and not ever the reason that they decide
that it's not a space for them
we have some dua requests before we stand for prayer
our sister suraya who many of you know she's in our graduating class this year her
grand uncle muhammad body passed away recently
as well as our sister frieza her uncle mansour
passed away a few hours ago after a long battle with lupus you make dua that
allah grants them both his infinite
peace in the grave and entrance into jannah without any judgment but we had another brother
muhammad hussain who passed away at the age of 47.
he's the brother of shanna's hussein a member of our community
please keep them in your prayers as well and we had many people who had reached
out that we emailed about dealing with illness and difficulties of various times read those things
make dua for them we make a collective prayer that allah makes these ailments and means
of purification in this world the means of elevation in the next grants ease to them
and all those who are in any state of distress at this time
in your name ya allah and beseech you to send your choices salutations upon your most
beloved sallallahu ta'ala that you will send them we ask that you shower your infinite mercy
upon this gathering granting each and every one who is present here in our loved ones
only the best in this world and the best in the next we ask allah that
if all of us are meant to be together only at this time at this place
whether we are young or old male or female regardless of our race our ethnicity our
social class our country of origin our cultural heritage whether we are muslim or come from
a different walk of life
our individual hearts are meant to be in the presence of all of their hearts that
are gathered here only at this time at this place and gather us all together again
in the best of places in the world beyond this one increases ya allah in all
that is good increases encourage compassion and confidence protect us from any affliction anxiety or anguish
removed from our hearts any feelings of bitterness jealousy animosity or envy towards any of your
creation grant us hearts that are filled with understanding and hope parts that are truly drawn
towards those things that are good and beautiful hearts define themselves deep in your remembrance for
indeed in your remembrance do your hearts find rest
make us from amongst those
who reach and benefit from the coming month of ramadan
help each one of us to utilize these days of sha'gon to the best of our
ability
so that the people we are as individuals are able to meet that first day in
the best state possible
help us to find meaning in every success and achievement as well as every mistake and
failure throughout all of it allah make it a means through which we draw closer to
you and gain recognition of the presence of your divine love and mercy
for these students will be their first time being in a ramadan here on campus
for our community members who are coming back and will be joining us as well we
ask allah that for all of us and our loved ones that you make it an
experience that is uplifting and fulfilling
one that rejuvenates our hearts and replenishes parts of ourselves that we didn't even know were
in need of rejuvenation
make it a means through which we draw closer to you ya
and throughout it all help us to take advantage of every moment that comes to our
way leaving not any of it behind
protect us always from parts that are not humble tongues that are not wise and eyes
that have forgotten how to cry forgive us for our shortcomings and guide and bless us
all rabbana